le prix qui lui était décerné
jean tirole nous fait un très grand
honneur que d'être ici devant la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat
vous avez déjà frotté les souliers dans
les couloirs du sénat bascule hier vous
étiez à l'émission jean-pierre elkabbach
qui sera diffusé à partir une croix de
vendredi dans le cadre de bibliothèque
médicis et je voulais rencontrer à
l'issue de cette de cette émission que
j'ai vu de l'autre côté de la porte en
direct et qui m'a mis en appétit par
rapport à ce que nous pouvons entendre
de vous cet après midi vous dire et je
m'exprime au nom de mes collègues que
nous sommes évidemment tout à fait
honorés de vous accueillir aujourd'hui
l'année 2014 aura été riche pour la
france
nous avons trois prix nobel qui ont été
décerné à un français est aujourd'hui
cette récompense vient consacrer votre
travail d'économistes au sein de la
prestigieuse toulouse couleurs avec al
mixte l ats dont vous êtes aujourd'hui
président sur laquelle il avait le
président alors votre modestie connu
légendaire vous a fait sursauter en
dirons non non non je ne suis pas
président et si voilà vous êtes vous
êtes monsieur le président ce sera
évidemment beaucoup plus facile pour
nous avant de revenir sur vos travaux
qui sont à s'y consacrer
je voudrais aussi insisté en préambule
sur le succès de la formule
universitaire qui se trouve ainsi
reconnu votre école d'économie peut être
qualifié de troisième voie en conciliant
à la fois pas le meilleur des grandes
écoles le meilleur de l'université et il
pourrait sans doute être intéressant d'y
réfléchir pour d'autres filières mais on
y reviendra sans doute tout à l'heure je
reviens à l'instant sur sur vos travaux
alors il est difficile de résumer vos
travaux vous allez illustré et bien vous
par votre présentation ce que vous avez
entrepris de démontrer alors je reprend
finalement une phrase qui revient qui
était repris souvent dans les
gazette qui ont parlé de jean tirole
prix nobel de l'économie ont dit vous
êtes reconnu comme le fondateur de
l'économie industrielle et votre apport
théorique et majeures s'agissant des
politiques de régulation
vous avez ainsi appliquer la théorie des
jeux à la régulation et aux oligopoles
en insistant sur la nécessité de réguler
au cas par cas en s'adaptant secteurs
d'activité concernés et il est précisé
que votre avons était partie en haïti
était utile dans le secteur des
télécommunications et de la banque
aujourd'hui il ya un secteur où l'on
parle beaucoup de régulation c'est celui
d'internet avec google microsoft amazon
et vos recommandations nous serons
évidemment tout à fait utile pour mettre
fin à des abus de position dominante qui
ont été concertées plus généralement et
pour me référer à l'actualité
vous apparaissez comme un homme qui
recommande des réformes mais aussi les
réformes d'urgence ce n'est pas une idée
nouvelle chez vous je me souviens de
votre contribution
avec olivier blanchard et ça remonte à
plus de dix ans dans un rapport où vous
parliez des contrats de travail et des
effets pervers des cdd par rapport au
cdi ou cdi par rapport aux cdd lui ai
fait des recommandations moi je était à
l'époque député à l'assemblée nationale
et j'avais été particulièrement
intéressés par la brillante
démonstration vous aviez fait fond vous
proposait à l'époque de fusionner les
contrats de travail c'est un sujet qui
d'après 2003 est toujours d'actualité
vous ne direz pas parce que je crois
deviner que vous n'êtes hommes à le dire
au syli franchement mais quelque part
vous devez recruter quand même que les
hommes politiques vous écoute avec
beaucoup de politesse mais ne met pas en
oeuvre certaines des recommandations que
vous faites avec pourtant une très
grande insistantes
alors voilà une introduction qui ne se
voulait pas exhaustive de vos travaux de
votre oeuvre de votre personnalité
mais qui nous permettait déjà d'orienter
les changes que nous allons avoir et
donc est ce que je peux vous suggérer de
de nous dire ce qui n'est pas facile à
l'évidence à faire pourquoi vous avez
été choisi pour être en 2014 le prix
nobel de l'économie
voilà vous appuyez sur le bouton très
bien merci monsieur le président et
merci pour votre invitation je suis
évidemment très honoré d'être ici
aujourd'hui parmi vous et vous commencez
par la question sans doute la plus
difficile parce que ça m'a étonné
moi-même le jour j'ai reçu le coup de
téléphone de stockholm de comprendre
pourquoi j'ai eu ce prix mais je
représente un courant qui est très bien
représentée à toulouse en particulier
mais plus généralement dans le monde de
gens qui ont étudié l'économie
industrielle est le nouveau rôle de
l'état l'état ce n'est plus l'état
producteurs comme autrefois c'est un
état qui est une espèce d'arbitrés qui
fait respecter les règles du jeu qui
fait attention effectivement qu' il n'y
a pas trop de défaillances de marché ce
qu'on appelle une défaillance de marché
et qui intéresse effectivement au bien
être économique générale alors pour ça
on a utilisé tous des modèles
enfin un titre à une ingénieure en
quelque sorte on essaie de capturer
l'essence du problème en regardant un
peu comment qu'est ce qui se passe pour
sept secteurs particuliers et on essaie
d'apporter des solutions à long terme
d'interventions publiques sachant qu'un
modèle c'est toujours qu'un modèle donc
il faut après il faut essayer le tester
comme comme commando de l'ingénieur il
faut essayer de tester alors si possible
avec des données ensemble la statistique
éventuellement dans un laboratoire pour
voir les comportements des gens et on
essaie après de faire des
recommandations de politique économique
qui soit à peu près robuste c'est
possible
et c'est ce qu'on appelle en particulier
la nouvelle économie industrielle donc
la nouvelle économie industrielle
c'est une combinaison du droit de la
concurrence donc essayer de comprendre
quels sont les comportements qui peuvent
être nocifs à la société le droit des
fusions c'est quand on côtoie temps
accepté la fusion de deux entreprises
toutes sortes de comportements de ce
type est aussi la régulation donc la
régulation c'est tout d'abord la
régulation des des industries de réseau
donc l'été vous savez les télécoms donc
les les chemins de fer l'électricité ou
y ait des problèmes de concurrence qui
sont des problèmes de concurrence non
non je dirais bien parce que ya ce qu'on
appelle des goulots d'étranglement vous
aurez vous allez pas avoir cinq réseaux
électriques en france où cinq réseaux de
chemins de fer c'est totalement
impossible donc on a des situations
assez naturel de monopole mes skis de
pause et prennent de concurrence donc
une partie de notre travail à toulouse
en particulier jean jacques lafon mais
d'autres avec jean jacques lafon dans
les années 80 a commencé à travailler à
essayer de comprendre qu'est ce qui
allait devenir de ces secteurs comme les
télécoms électricité et autre secteur à
la fois en terme d'incitation des
entreprises puisque on avait les
entreprises dans le monde entier
s'étaient pas typiquement français qui
n'était pas très très efficace dans les
coups étaient était très coûteux bois
pour la collectivité est aussi la
traduction de la concurrence sur les
segments où ils pouvaient y aura de la
concurrence
donc c'est là dessus qu'on a travaillé
sachant que c'est pas évidemment une
liste exhaustive des défaillances de
marché c'est à dire que il ya d'autres
différences de marché vous prenez par
exemple l'environnement
on va laisser une date climatique à nos
enfants qui est absolument gigantesque
et clairement il s'agit de prendre des
mesures assez rapidement on espère que
comme 21 ne sera pas la même chose que
copenhague kyoto et comme tous les
exemplaires précédent pas des voeux
pieux mais vraiment des engagements
contraignants et donc les économies
c'est évidemment se sont penchés depuis
très très longtemps sur les questions
d'environnement et sur la façon
justement dans tout pouvait réguler
l'environnement la pollution sans
imposer un coût trop élevé nous en
trouvons ici requins
ah ah émissions de gaz à effet serre par
exemple donner quand on fait on pour
limiter le coût pour les entreprises
aussi on limite pas le coût pour les
entreprises
le programme sera non crédible on
n'arrivera jamais à combattre les gaz à
effet de serre donc c'était important
l'autre dimension que vous avez cité
monsieur le président au 6è c'est la
question de des banques et que la
facture qu'elles peuvent laisser
évidemment aux contribuables à l'argent
public et donc il s'agit de les régler
correctement dans tout ça ce sont des
travaux qui ont été faits par les
économistes depuis une trentaine
d'années c'est ce qu'on appelle la
nouvelle économie industrielle
je ne suis qu'un des chercheurs qui a
travaillé là-dessus bon j'ai eu la
chance effectivement d'avoir d'avoir
supprimé
c'est tout un courant dans le monde
entier on a beaucoup développé ces à
toulouse mais dans le monde entier en
courant de recherche sur ces sujets qui
est de la recherche quelque chose qui
m'a fait très plaisir d'ailleurs avec le
prix nobel
si vous lisez le document qui va avec le
prix nobel y un document de 52 pages qui
décrit pourquoi j'ai pris une manière
donc ou plutôt je dors hier pourquoi
notre collectivité a pris sur ce sujet
ce serait plus exact on a je pense qu'
il y ait ce qui m'a fait beaucoup
plaisir dans ce document c'est à
pratiquer le fait qu'on fait la
recherche fondamentale est que cette
recherche fondamentale a beaucoup
d'application on dissocie souvent la
recherche fondamentale et les
applications
mais c'est vrai que la recherche ont
fait a eu beaucoup d'impact directement
dans les autorités de régulation dans
les autorités de la concurrence à bruch
à bruxelles à washington à paris et
ailleurs dans les banques centrales
donc c'est quelque chose de très
pratique même si fondamentalement on
fait de la recherche pure au départ à
prendre celle appliquée un petit peu
mais c'est notre notre coeur de métier
c'est quand même la recherche
fondamentale donc c'est un coté qui
m'inquiete m'a beaucoup plu dans la
citation nobel parce que ça fait ça
montre qu'il n'y a pas de d'antagonisme
entre cette recherche fondamentale et
les applications pour la société voilà
je sais pas si j'ai répondu que je pense
qu'on va avoir un état un échange un peu
interactif mais après je pourrais vous
donner quelques exemples de travaux
compte
mais je sais pas comment je me dévoue
maintenant et des exemples concrets
parce que je peux vous donner des
exemples récents par exemple nos corps
prenons l'exemple la propriété
intellectuelle donc la propriété
intellectuelle c'est un sujet très
important pour l'avenir de nos sociétés
puisque la 21ème siècle siècle de la
connaissance donc c'est les emplois vont
se créer pas mal à partir la propriété
intellectuelle il y avait de gros débats
autour de la propriété intellectuelle il
ya beaucoup de brevets en particulier
qui ont été décernés par les offices de
brevets souvent trop d'ailleurs et mais
ça veut dire que quand vous les
implémenter une technologie vous êtes
obligé automatiquement d'enfreindre ou
de vendre des licences sur un certain
nombre de brevets peut-être 20 30 40 qui
sont possédés par différentes
entreprises
donc si vous avez sept ou huit
entreprises qui ont des brevets pour
implémenter votre technologie vous avez
vous devez a signé des contrats de
licence avec sept ou huit entreprises
la conséquence c'est qu'il ya sept ou
huit entreprises qui peuvent vous taxer
et ont un droit de péage sur la
technologie et si vous avez sept ou huit
entreprises qui ont un droit de péage
sur la technologie ça veut dire que la
technologie va coûter extrêmement cher
et ne va pas se diffuser c'est pas
nouveau
on le sait depuis le moyen-âge vous
prenez toutes les rivières françaises ou
le rein ou l'elbe au moyen-âge
vous aviez des péages tout le long
chacun prélevait sa séance oph sa dîme
comment s'appelait à l'époque et le coût
total de naviguer sur un flou avait très
très cher et très très élevé le rhin
avait 64 péage au 14e siècle n'oubliez
pas alors on a compris que cette
situation n'est pas bonne elle n'est pas
bonne évidemment pour les utilisateurs
qui se font taxer de nombreuses fois
mais elle n'est pas bonne non plus pour
le pour ceux qui taxent puisque chacun
prélevant s'attaque ça veut dire que le
coût total est très élevé et
automatiquement
on a très peu de navigation en cas de du
rein ou de la scène si très peu de très
peu de
de diffusion de la technologie dans le
cas des technologies à qu'est ce qu'on a
trouvé comme comme solution on a trouvé
une solution qui en fait était à
utiliser énormément en 1945 c'est à dire
le regroupement des brevets ce que ça
veut dire techniquement s'appelle un
pool de brevets ça veut dire que en fait
les sept oui détenteurs de brevets se
mettent ensemble et donne une licence
pour le package 17 libre des dénés des
20 ou 30 brevets qu'il possède aux
utilisateurs cela permet éventuellement
de diminuer le prix puisque ils peuvent
se mettre ensemble et dire on est en
train de tuer l'industrie
on va diminuer le prix est en fait
c'était le modèle qui était utilisée
avant 1945 partout dans pratiquement
tous les secteurs vous le savez
peut-être pas mais vous prenez les
secteurs aux technologies de l'époque
avant 1945 c'était l'aviation c'est à la
télévision c'était l'automobile c'était
le chemin de fer c'était des choses
comme ça ils étaient tous là et la
chimie aussi été organisés autour de
poules de province circulent les
détenteurs de brevets les octroyer des
licences de façon collective et en 1945
la cour suprême américaine a dit on
arrête on ne veut plus de pools de
brevets parce que ça peut être utilisé à
bon escient
c'est le cas de fectivement canton
regroupe les brevets pour les vendre
moins cher mais on peut les utiliser à
mauvais escient c'est le cas par exemple
de deux brevets substitut qu'on met
ensemble pour ne plus faire concurrence
monter les prix alors que la cour
suprême américaine les juges américains
ont dit on veut plus de pools de brevets
et ça cette situation a perduré tous
leurs atouts restant du 20e siècle et on
a vu que la fin du xxème siècle qu'on ne
les prenne considérable pour la
diffusion des technologies en biotech en
logiciels etc
donc nous ce qu'on a fait cette falloir
la recherche théorique pour essayer de
comprendre comment on pourrait filtrer
les bons poule ceux qui font baisser les
prix et éviter évidemment les poules qui
sont mauvais ce qu'il faut monter les
prix donc on a proposé des règles très
simples retrait dans les détails mais on
a improvisé des règles très simples qui
n'exige pas d'informations et ces règles
ont été adoptées en 2004 et en 2014 par
la commission européenne
c'est un exemple et on a fait de la
recherche pure c'est qu'on a fait la
recherche pure à toulouse qui a été
publié
mais revue internationale et plus tard à
ses huit dans le cas particulier c'était
un an plus tard ça a été adopté
adopté par la commission européenne art
parfois ça peut être adopté dix ans plus
tard parfois le plus souvent pas du tout
mais c'est un exemple mais vous avez
beaucoup de pools de brevets que là
dedans vous avez énormément de pools de
brevets c'est grâce à ça que vous avez
des smartphones tous les algorithmes de
compression 1 sont basées sur des pools
de brevets c'est ça qui permet la
diffusion la technologie alors vous avez
aussi se regarde dans notre poche vous
avez des cartes de crédit dans sur vous
et l'a de nouveau ses cartes de crédit
ou un modèle qui est assez intéressant à
modèle ce qu'on appelle l'amour en
jargon des modèles me fasse il faut
attirer des deux côtés d'un marché donc
le problème pour visa ou mastercard
carte bleue et ses terrasses et d'avoir
à la fois les les détenteurs de cartes
qui ont utilisé leur carte est aussi les
bas les commerçants qui acceptent la
carte et donc et ils ont développé un
modèle qui en gros et le même modèle de
google pour l'internet
alors votre votre carte de paiement et
très bon marché souvent maintenant
étrangers on ne peut même plus pour une
carte de paiement
on peut même être payé pour l'utiliser
c'est là qu'on peut avoir des mal soudés
des bonus quand on utilise mais
inversement évidemment les commerçants
paient et les commerçants sont en
général pas très content et donc ça ça
pose la question est ce que ces systèmes
que ce soit american express visa
mastercard est ce qu'elles font et les
bonnes commissions commerçants d'un
point de vue social
il faut la diffusion des cartes il faut
pas faire payer trop cher aux
commerçants ecsta donc de nouveau on a
fait des recherches à toulouse et on a
on était terminée un critère pour
déterminer quelles sont les bonnes
commissions commerçants alors c'est un
critère théorique après il faut faire
tout le côté empirique pour essayer de
mesurer tout ça mais ce critère le
critère officiel maintenant de la
commission européenne pour réguler visa
et mastercard par exemple c'est cesser
les accords une forme et de nouveau on a
publiés dans les revues internationales
puis ça c'est diffuser la connaissance
et des fusées petit à petit et ça a été
utilisée locks c'est le genre de choses
qu'on fait on fait de la recherche
fondamentale on essaie de réfléchir un
peu tranquillement ça met toujours un
pas de temps et impactant très élevé est
au bout d'un certain
en parfois si on a la chance bien ses
recherches sont appliquées alors qu'ils
faisait allusion tout à l'heure et après
je donnerai la parole à mes collègues
qui souhaitent intervenir
on ne parle que de réformes depuis déjà
quelques années sans vous conduire sur
un terrain que vous avez choisi ne pas
être le vôtre
quelles sont les recommandations
principales que vous feriez à un
gouvernement de la planète
on va pas parler d'une autre mais à
gouvernements de la planète qui
souhaitent au 21ème siècle se réformer
et se mettre en état d'être
concurrentiels d'avoir le plein emploi
de satisfaire les requêtes des citoyens
et finalement d'assurer le bonheur des
peuples
c'est une grande question c'est très
compliqué tout d'abord il ya les
problèmes qui sont globaux donc je suis
tel environnement les gaz à effet de
serre c'est un problème mondial sa part
l'importance qu'on émette en france en
chine ou ailleurs c'est une tonne de co2
c'est une tonne de cieux de point final
et as lutté contre le gaz à effet de
serre n'est pas un premier conomique on
sait faire on sait très bien faire sa
part m entièrement politique à problèmes
économiques
il a été montré à la fois par les
théoriciens mais aussi par les économies
s'appliquer que la meilleure façon de
lutter contre les gaz à effet de serre
ou tout autre opulence est pas
spécifique à gaz à effet de serre c'est
d'avoir un prix du carbone dans le cas
des gaz à effet de serre c'est l'avant
un prix du carbone et de pas trop essayé
d'intervenir parce qu'on n'a pas
l'information dans la façon dont on fait
les économies
donc on donne une indication que le prix
du carbone en pratique ça se fait pour
parler droits d'émissions négociables
qu'on pourra en discuter parce que les
problèmes techniques tout à fait
intéressant j'avais écrit d'ailleurs un
rapport du cae du conseiller économique
au sujet de copenhague où je m'étais
montré d'ailleurs assez pessimiste sur
copenhague mais
on sait le faire prenez l'exemple du so2
aux états unis en 1990 il ya eu un
accord bi partisan aux états unis sur le
so2 pour diminuer la pollution de moitié
ce qui permet d' énormes
la pollution a diminué de moitié dans la
durée en a mis en place un système
d'émission de droits d'émissions
négociables
ça a eu un coût qui as à limiter le coût
pour les entreprises parce que si vous
commencez aller dans le détail on dit
vous réduisez vous réduisez pas c'est à
dire que les gens qui vont pas réduire
axa coûterait 1 euro de réduire la
pollution d'une tonne et d'autres qui
vont payer 100 euros pour réduire la
pollution d'une tonne donc on est en
train de gâcher des ressources et on
pourrait réduire la pollution beaucoup
plus haut même coup un donc la façon
dont les économistes tous les
économistes sont à peu près d'accord là
dessus c'est qu'il faut avoir un prix du
carbone mais il faut avoir un prix du
carbone mondial
et là on est vraiment dans le mondial
parce que si la france fait le fait des
efforts ce que je souhaite
ces efforts ont un impact de façon très
très limité parce que évidemment il ya
des fuites donc la production polluante
en france va se faire en chine ou
ailleurs dans les pays où justement il
n'y aura pas de prix du carbone donc ça
veut dire qu'on réduit pas forcément la
pollution même en faisant des choses
vertueuse donc c'est quand même un petit
peu délicat donc là c'est pour ça que je
lisais un c'est un problème politique
s'apprennent d'accord mondial
contraignant servons jusqu'ici et
concentrant contracté à kyoto copenhague
etc
on disait ben écoutez vous inquiétez pas
en 2050 serait réduit mon les gaz à
effet de serre de temps ça fait c'est
gratuit ça coûte rien ça n'avance à rien
et on fait ce qu'il faut c'est vraiment
avoir des accords contraignants alors on
pourra entrer plus en détails parce que
j'ai une vision assez claire de ce qu'il
faut faire mais c'est c'est vraiment ça
pas prendre l'économie qu'on sait faire
on sait en sait exactement comment faire
mes collègues à tous à toulouse dont
directeur de la ts qui part qui
appartient depuis plusieurs plusieurs
fois où j acques a participé de
nombreuses forêts giec hommes comme
rapporteur
on sait faire c'est pas la question la
question c'est comment faire en sorte
que tout le monde soit autour de la
table et disent collectivement on va
faire quelque chose et on va arrêter ce
carnage parce que là on est en train de
laisser à nos enfants quand même un
monde
inquiets qui est abominable donc on a
une responsabilité collective je pense
au niveau mondial pour faire quelque
chose
merci je vais donner la parole elisabeth
lamure merci monsieur président c'est le
président tyrol nous sommes en effet
très honoré de votre visite parmi nous
merci pour vos propos très clairs et en
même temps très concret moi j'aurai deux
simples questions
tout d'abord on dit que les français
sont très mauvais élève en économie et
je suis pas loin de le croire
or aujourd'hui l'économie est vraiment
présente dans notre vie quotidienne
surtout depuis qu'elle mondialisé et
qu'elle prend toutes sortes de formes et
les circulaires et les solidaires et les
industriels est ce que vous ne pensez
pas que c'est une matière qui devrait
être très présente dans les programmes
scolaires
et puis ma deuxième question sur sur
l'activité économique française
donc les points qui pèse le plus et qui
sont des freins à notre activité
économique on parle du poids des normes
de la lourdeur administrative et de
l'importance des prélèvements
obligatoires
est-ce que vous pensez que nous avons
atteint avoir dépassé le seuil de
tolérance est est ce que le taux de 57 %
de dépenses publiques par rapport aux
pipes vous paraît supportable ou
insupportables sur merci très bien je
remercie et ça on l'est évidemment des
questions difficiles sur l'enseignement
de l'économie
je ne suis pas spécialiste ya eu
beaucoup de rapports enfin je suis pas
spécialiste dans le secondaire
évidemment je suis plus spécialiste dans
les universités je pense qu'on doit
faire des grands est fou de gros efforts
pour l'enseignement de l'économie dégâts
y compris à l'université c'est à dire
qu' il faut que l'économie deviennent
plus concrète je pense que c'est
important d'avoir des économies sérieuse
dans les universités
et il faut aussi qu'on parle du monde
réel et des armes en tant qu on danse on
enseigne des techniques parce que que
souvent eu d'incident grandes écoles la
plupart des gens qui appartient qui
apprennent l'économie ne sont ne sont
pas des futurs doctorants ou des futurs
professeurs d'économie
j'ai travaillé à un moment pendant ce
temps où el maati comme professeur je
voyais effectivement tous ces ingénieurs
jeunes ingénieurs ils prenaient tous un
cours d'économie et c'était la très très
bonne économie
au début c'était avec semelle sonne et
d'autre mais il sait la très bonne
économie donc il ressortait alors bien
sûr il était ingénieur après donc il
n'était pas forcément mais ils en
ressentent avec des notions d'économie
importante
c'est donc ce n'était pas seulement
faire des maths parce que c'était pas
difficile quand on est ingénieur du rail
si on est très très fort en maths c'est
très facile de faire l'économie qu'avec
des maths mais on je pense que c'est
important d'avoir à quelque chose de
concret alors après il ya eu beaucoup de
critiques sur effectivement ce qui se
passe dans le secondaire et
l'enseignement dans le secondaire il
faut pas se leurrer il faut il faut
l'améliorer
il faut améliorer de façon générale la
culture économique en france la culture
économique dans le monde entier est
faible en france allez franchement
mauvaise alors pourquoi pourquoi parfois
c'est notre responsabilité en tant que
professeur c'est là que je pense qu'il
ya quand même une une amélioration de la
qualité du personnel de l'université par
exemple je pense que la qualité des
professeurs à monter et puis il faut
qu'on fasse des efforts aussi pour
enseigner mieux il ya aussi le fait que
la france était une économie très
administrée donc c'est vrai que quand
vous avez un problème je permets de
droit la concurrence quelque chose sur
lequel j'ai beaucoup travaillé le droit
la concurrence dans le temps ben si vous
avez un problème est que le ministère
prenne de concurrence
je caricature bien sûr vous appelez le
ministre vous étiez pdg vous appelez le
ministre vous étiez dire voilà ce qui
fait le plus important c'était ça
maintenant c'est pas vrai le droit de la
concurrence c'est complètement différent
il faut aller à bruxelles ou même à
paris au sort et de la concurrence il
faut utiliser des arguments économiques
et les relations ne servent plus à grand
chose et ça ça déplace complètement le
terrain les banques centrales c'est
pareil vous allez
à francfort vous allez à paris partout
ailleurs maintenant le débat dans les
banques centrales et un débat économique
donc il faut que notre pays soit ce
niveau et on a tous une responsabilité
les politiques vous nous les professeurs
les chercheurs les journalistes
on a tous une responsabilité collective
pour faire passer des messages
économique
alors après sur la lourdeur
administrative
j'irai la chose on doit choisir un
modèle un modèle convoque je crois qu'en
france on a choisi un modèle social
personnellement h au partage
mais le modèle social ne ne veut pas
dire une administration pléthorique veut
pas dire une des prélèvements très élevé
ou alors il faut une qualité qui
correspond et moi je m'inquiète un petit
peu c'est vrai qu'on a des meilleurs des
médailles fields mais c'est vrai qu'au
classement des mathématiques en france
on a toujours des normaliens des
politiciens remarquable mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est aussi la personne dans
l'iss et moyens français et aux
classements internationaux on n'est pas
très on n'est pas brillant donc les
médailles fields sont l'arbre qui
cachait enfin c'est quand même assez un
peu dangereux de même il faut pas se
compter sur les primes des prix nobel et
c'est ce qui compte c'est ce qu'il ya
derrière
c'est beaucoup plus important donc il
faut il faut des soins de qualité il
faut les enseignements de qualité il
faut rétablir l'ascenseur social qui est
disparu il faut bien dire dans les
grandes très grandes écoles las en
sciences sociales à cames disparu alors
qu'il faut un service public de qualité
et je crois qu'on est tous très attachés
en france a service public de qualité
mais il faut arriver à le rendre
soutenable et pour ça il va falloir
faire des réformes
alors je prendrai l'exemple de quatre
pays que vous connaissez
l'allemagne la suède l'australie le
canada ce sont des pays qui sont
attachés au service public et en
particulier pays scandinaves tous des
composantes commun commune ils ont tous
gardé leur modèle social en faisant les
réformes rendent en ayant un état plus
léger
et tout ça il en fait souche à un moment
où il y avait des difficultés
l'allemagne s'était effectivement en
2003-2004 à les digérer encore mal la
réunification la suède c'était au moment
de la crise
juste après la crise de 1991 et sexy
dans le canada l'australie et même chose
deuxième point commun toutes les
réformes ont été faites par les
socialistes et la droite quand elle est
revenue au pouvoir les a conservées donc
une des leçons aussi c'est qu'une
réforme c'est quelque chose dans la
durée à une réforme qu'on fait pour une
réforme importante qu'on fait pendant
deux ans ça sert pas à grand chose
il faut que ce soit quelque chose qui
dure et donc il faut un accord bi
partisan minimal ce qui est des
changements de majorité et je pense que
c'est vraiment important de comprendre
ce fait est un défi national
si on veut garder notre modèle social et
si on veut garder nos retraites
il va falloir faire en sorte que l'état
soit plus léger tout en gardant les
mêmes choses et donc pour ça il faut
qu'ils aient un accord bi partisan pour
que l'on fasse ses réformes et les pays
comme la suède le canada l'australie et
par exemple ont très bien montrer qu'on
peut faire ces réformes et on peut
diminuer l'armement le poids du public
tout en gardant exactement les mêmes
services et choc ce choix que c'est un
message très fort qui nous envoie et il
ne faut pas attendre parce qu'on est
dans des situations effectivement ou la
dette est très importante on parle de la
dette publique officielle mais aussi la
dette au bilan 1 qu'il faut pas oublier
il ya des retraites ya ceux ci il ya
cela donc il va falloir pour l'instant
on s'en tire bien je pense que j'en suis
très heureuse et en français j'espère
que ça va continuer mais il faut quand
même faire attention au fait que quand
les choses se dégradent
elle se dégrade un peu lentement en
france à quand les choses se dégradent
on n'est pas à la merci on est on est à
merci par dont deux d'une attaque
spéculative une attaque des marchés
et là ça devient auto réalisateur et
inclut le danger d'une attaque
spéculative c'est que tout d'un coup les
marchés s'inquiètent
les taux d'intérêt montent ils sont
extrêmement bas pour l'instant ils
montrent tout à coup et monte à 6 7 8 %
mais ces auto réalisateur parce que si
vous avez tout l'intérêt qu'ils sont
très élevés ça veut dire que la charge
de l'emprunt est très élevé et à ce
moment là ça veut dire que votre déficit
augmente vos dettes augmentent ils
augmentent les taux les spread augmenté
ainsi de suite
et là on l'a on a du mal à s'en sortir
alors l'italie et l'espagne sont sortis
grâce à l'imbécile donc grâce en partie
à l'allemagne il faut bien dire ce qui
est et donc ça veut dire que si ça
arrive à la france ce sera quand même
difficile de tenir
j'espère que ça va arriver on ne peut
pas prédire si ça va arriver où et quand
ça va mieux parce que c'est par
définition autant les fondamentaux les
voit évoluer ça c'est très clair
par contre ce qui est beaucoup plus
difficile c'est de prévoir une attaque
spéculative des marchés qui par
définition est auto réalisatrices donc
ça peut ne pas arriver comme ça peut
arriver dans quinze jours c'est très
complexe
est ce qu'il faut c'est sorti de sortir
de cette zone parce que à partir du
moment où il ya des attaques
spéculatives ça veut dire que on a plus
de degrés de liberté du tout car le pire
c'est évidemment d'avoir le fmi à paris
c'est clair qu'on n'a pas envie d'avoir
ça mais c'est la chose c'est la chose
qui peut arriver donc je souhaite
vraiment que ça n'arrive pas et pour ça
je pense qu'il faut se crédibiliser par
des réformes donc c'est un petit peu mon
thème mon rôle attention à mon rôle
c'est pas le vôtre je suis un chercheur
d'envoi mon rôle c'est d'avoir des idées
d'ong et de donner mon opinion c'est pas
moi qui est qui doit effectivement je
suis dans un rôle très limité et
évidemment monsieur le président je veux
rester effectivement en dehors des
aspects politiques de la chose que je ne
contrôle pas et que je ne maîtrise pas
mais je pense qu'il est important quand
même de maîtriser le jour ce qui m'avait
frappé le jour de la lance du prix nobel
sait on passe le téléphone
enfin ces téléphones j'ai pas l'habitude
moi j'ai pas du tout l'habitude des
médias et tout d'un coup j'ai un coup de
téléphone tous les cinq minutes et je
répondais en français ou en anglais
et puis quand je réponde en anglais
avait parfois chez m puis à qui je
parlais mais quand répondant en anglais
la première question c'était quand la
france va-t-elle couler ça me choque est
un petit peu mais merde c'est d'abord
parce que les questions en france était
un petit peu différente et il y avait un
peu de french bashing comme a dit le
premier ministre
mais c'est quand même quelque chose qui
est dans les esprits et cc pour un
français je trouve que c'est assez
difficile à vivre bien je vais donner la
parole à yannick vaugrenard
oui merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur tyrol d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et nous faire profiter de vos
recherches et de vos propos au début de
votre intervention tout à l'heure vous
avez
indiquez vous venez de le rappeler la
nécessité de réformes d'urgence et du
nouveau rôle de l'état je serais tenté
de dire et des états que nous vivons
dans une économie bien entendu
mondialisée vous l'avez dit et arbitres
au bien-être économique générale vune
souligné que nous n'étions pas à l'abri
d'attaqués spéculatives éventuellement
qui risquerait de de monter les taux
d'intérêt extrêmement bas de nos
bénéficions aujourd'hui
et du coup ça m'amène une question sur
le système financier et bancaire
international la crise de 2008 a mené
l'ensemble des états et notamment les
états développés à prendre des décisions
importantes notamment sur les fonds
propres des principales banques
mondiales
pour autant nous savons aujourd'hui
qu'il ay à d'autres systèmes qui
existent qui sont spéculatifs qui sont
proches du juge et du hasard et qui sont
en marge des banques elles mêmes et qui
manifestement dans leur comportement
dans leurs objectifs dans les risques
qu'elles prennent
ce ne sont absolument pas au service de
l'économie contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait parfois imaginez donc ma
question selon vous quels contrôles
supplémentaires pourraient exister pour
être se mettre en place au niveau
international pour éviter ces risques
qui sont extrêmement dangereux et qui
pourrait nous conduire à une crise des
subprimes x un sombre de sa tombe deux
fois dont comment faire pour être plus
efficace au niveau international ensuite
deuxième point
on peut se satisfaire du fait que
l'allemagne éventuellement peut s'en
satisfaire a eu un taux de croissance au
dernier trimestre de 0 1% et nous 0 3%
pour autant si l'allemagne se mettaient
à dévisser est-ce que cela risquerait
pas de nous entraîner dans une spirale
infernale sur le plan économique et
financier
et enfin le fait que l'allemagne est un
pays extrêmement fragile sur le plan de
son évolution démographique ne
considérez vous pas que sur le plan
économique c'est un peu un colosse aux
pieds d'argile
troisième point s'appelle une question
qui peut apparaître de détails mais je
profite de votre présence pour éclairer
ma lanterne
nous sommes un des pays où il y a le
plus fort taux d'épargné notamment au
niveau de la suite de l'assurance vie
allez vous le sentiment que nous
utilisons suffisamment s'était pas renié
extrêmement forte au service
éventuellement d'une relance même
modérée de la croissance
je suis remercie beaucoup ce sont des
questions très importantes alors la
première question c'est est sûre sur la
réglementation prudentielle des banques
est d'abord l'aspect international donc
moi je me suis fait longtemps que je
suis partisan de l'union bancaire pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison
c'est que ya une asymétrie d'information
très forte entre les banques et leurs
superviseurs les banques sont
extrêmement sophistiqués ont des talents
et le superviseur a des ressources
limitées a du mal d'ailleurs à faire
concurrence pour les talents qui sont
payés très très cher par les banques et
donc c'est très difficile d'être
régulateurs et je vois pas comment au
niveau 2 de la zone euro on pourra avoir
un certain nombre de régulateurs
compétents donc foulé les compères les
compétences ça me paraît tout à fait
important de donner quelque chose
d'encore beaucoup plus important c'est
d'avoir une régulation qui est plus en
plus indépendantes arrêt plus
indépendante pour deux raisons d'abord
parce qu'elle est la bce qui en théorie
indépendante mais aussi parce qu'elle
est en dehors du pays en partie il ya
bien sûr la régulation va se faire avec
des citoyens du pays bien sûr mais je
prenais l'exemple de l'espagne
c'est très intéressant ce qui s'est
passé en espagne un rapport du fmi sur
l'espagne à quelques ya deux ans ce pur
qui est tout à fait intéressant sur
l'espagne vous avez vu la crise
espagnole vous allez les drames sociaux
que ça a créé pour les citoyens
espagnols
tout ça à cause des banques espagnoles
maintenant je vais vous dire quelque
chose qui va vous surprendre
le régulateur espagnol est un des
meilleurs régulateur au monde regarde
bancaire espagnol est un des meilleurs
régulateur au bond
vous parlez aux banquiers centraux ils
vous diront tous que c'est laid parmi
les plus talentueux d'ailleurs il avait
mis en garde dès 2005 contre ce qui
laisse passer
la banque d'espagne la banque centrale
avait mis en garde le gouvernement
espagnol et les gouvernements régionaux
contre ce qui allait se passer
mais dans le cas particulier le
régulateur a été bail passé a été
contournée et le gouvernement central et
les régions on voulait encourager
l'immobilier de même que george bush a
voulu encourager l'immobilier aux états
unis
même cause même effet débâcle bancaire
évidemment les fonds publics sont
appelés pour et après les sacrifices
pour l'épauler citoyen est donc il ya
une leçon à faire et apprendre dans là
dedans c'est que il s'agit un peu de
rands la supervision un peu indépendante
de sorte que on a une mesure objective
alors maintenant est-ce que ça va
marcher ou pas on va voir la suite des
stress tests est un bon exemple pour
pour essayer de réfléchir si ça va
marcher mais il s'agit d'avoir une
régulation plus forte
cette régulation plus forte pour moi
l'union bancaire a au moins le potentiel
de la créer sinon si on a des relations
de connivence entre les banques et les
états je pense qu'on est dans une
situation délicate
alors vous poser les questions sur le
château banking e vous êtes peut-être un
petit peu moi je suis inquiet du shadow
banking des banques de l'ombre celles
qui ne sont pas régulés qu'elle soit
passée alizé l'économie s'est pas tout à
fait vrai pas toujours elles peuvent
être au service de l'économie aux états
unis 50 % des prêts aux pme sont faits
par cheyrou banking
askia ce qui est un peu inquiétant aussi
par ailleurs mais elles servent aussi
l'économie parce qu'elle dirige des
crédits faire vers l'économie alors la
question est la suivante c'est celle de
la migration cercle on a une régulation
bancaire qui a été complètement laxiste
avant la crise de 2008
c'est une bonne chose en laxisme c'est
dans les périodes fastes et puis
évidemment ça près par la crise donc
après la crise on commence à dire oui
mais il faut faire attention on va
demander aux banques d'avoir beaucoup de
sûreté alors on pourra parler par la
suite de la pénibilité de la pénurie
d'actifs sûrs qu'il ya problème sérieux
actuellement je vais en parler et le
prendre la stagnation segula séculaire
mais on demande de plus en plus actif
sur pour être sûr qu'il ya que les
banques sautois surcontrôlés contre les
problèmes économiques très bien mais ça
veut dire aussi que les pillards de
migration de l'activité cirque on peut
avoir ce qui s'est passé aux etats-unis
c'est que les banques de détail telles
qu'on les connaît en france n'est plus
de marché et qu'en fait ce sont les
banques d'investissement et puis les
hedge fund et puis les autres qui
commence à servir finalement les pme a
commencé à faire ça alors ça pose la
question suivante se pose la question de
l'égalité de la concurrence dire que si
on met trop de contraintes sur les
banques de détail et les compagnies
d'assurance parce qu'il ya aussi sur le
28 ou sur l'habilité 2 ça veut dire que
l'activité risque de se déplacer vers le
shadow banking et le shadow banking
relancer un secteur par définition qui
fait de la transformation dire que tout
le monde fait la transformation cirque
on emprunte en gros on emprunte à court
terme pour prêter à long terme
seulement les banques de détail font de
la transformation en n'ayant le back up
de la banque centrale donc on peut avoir
des liquidités l on voit assurances
dépôt qui est stabilisé choses aussi ce
que n'ont pas à les banques de l'ombre
alors soit elles font concurrence
mais quelque chose qui m'a choqué la
crise de 2008 mais qui est très clair ça
c'est très clair pourquoi c'est que les
banques d'investissement ont été sauvés
donc on avait des banques qui n'était
pas
gueuler et qui en même temps ont eu
accès à l'argent du contribuable est
donc là il ya un problème fondamental
parce que l on le beurre et l'argent du
beurre puisque d'une part elles sont pas
régulés n'ont pas de contrainte et
d'autre part elles ont accès à l'argent
du contribuable et de la banque centrale
du contribuable donc c'est quand même un
problème assez important qu'il faut il
faut tenir en compte
donc là il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs
réponses à cette question une question
la réponse qui est donnée dans les
instances internationales c'est on va
contrôler les banques systémiques celles
contre on se sentira obligé de sauver
parce que si elles éclatent les banques
pas seulement de détails mais les
banques d'investissement les fonds et c6
et clape et valeur des aspects
systémiques
alors je dis oui très bien mais dans ce
cas-là augmenter les ressources pour les
superviseurs parce que les superviseurs
bancaires ont déjà beaucoup de mal à
réguler les banques de détail les
compagnies d'assurance et aux etats-unis
fonds de pension et puis vous leur
demandez maintenant de réguler aussi les
banques d'investissement vous leur
demandez des règles et des hedge funds
demain vous leur demanderez de réguler
les compagnies d'électricité parce que
les compagnies d'électricité un travail
sur des produits dérivés donc on s'étend
de seraient produits dérivés etc
où va où va-t-on arrêter il faut leur
donner des ressources
donc on peut pas simplement dire les
régulateurs vous surveiller tout et ne
pas leur donner une ressource est pas
possible
l'autre possibilité c'est d'éviter les
effets systémiques et de ce côté-là je
trouve l'évolution encore trop lente
mais l'évolution vers les chambres de
compensation et marché centralisée et
une très bonne évolution
non pas que je sois contre les marchés
de gré à gré mais les marchés de gré à
gré sont très difficiles à comprendre
marché de gré à gré ce sont des des
transactions très spécialisés entre
entre bandes par exemple qui sont des
produits extrêmement complexe qui sont
spécialisés aux deux institutions
concernées et que trois ou quatre
personnes dans le monde comprenne donc
pour le régulateur le superviseur
bancaire c'est vraiment très dur de
suivre qu'il s'y passe sur ses marchés
de gré à gré donc pourquoi on a sauvé à
igé la banque d'investissement par la
compagnie d'assurances qui était une
compagnie tellement scène
c'est la bande d'avis mans l'a sauvé
parce qu'on savait pas qu est ce qui
allait se passer une fois qu'on a appuyé
sur le bouton on dit vous couler après
tout c'est une banque d'investissement
il ya même pas de petits déposants etc
on aurait pu très bien appuyé sur le
bouton et bien comme on l'avait fait
avec liman mais à ce moment là on savait
pas ce qui allait se passer parce qu'on
n'a aucune idée de tous ses produits
dérivés qui avait émis un avis j'ai donc
les champs de les marchés centralisée
salle avantage qui a une certaine
transparence ya des prix il ya des
appels de marge
il ya une évaluation du risque par le
superviseur donc on leur facilite le
travail et c'est ça que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut comprendre on leur
facilite le travail
ils ont beaucoup de mal je reviens
toujours au thème des économies c'est
l'information asymétrique
les banques ont infiniment plus
d'informations que leurs superviseurs
sauce kalfon c'est normal mais essayons
de réduire cette information à 6 mais
cette asymétrie d'information à fond
afin de rendre le travail des
superviseurs plus facile alors on pourra
parler par la suite il ya quand même
encore beaucoup d'incertitudes sur le
monde financier sa régulation et sans
supervision pouvoir y revenir là dessus
parce que c'est pas terminé je pense
qu'on a été dans la bonne voie depuis
2000 rythme et le trail loin d'être
finie alors sur sur l'allemagne
oui on espère qu'elle va pas dévisser
moi je suis relativement confiant quand
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que l'allemagne
ait fait ces réformes en 2003 2004 il y
avait effectivement qu'elle n'avait pas
encore complètement déchiré l'allemagne
de l'asthme est aussi je crois que vous
avez indiquée à juste titre l'évolution
démographique est vraiment très très
inquiétante en allemagne donc les
allemands ont compris que quand même là
il était il était face au mur ou bien il
serait fort mais ou diesel est pas s'en
sortir parce que d'un point de vue
finances publiques
donc ils ont fait les réformes qu'ils
avaient fait là il fallait ils ont fait
une réforme en particulier marché du
travail et d'autres réformes
ça a été très courageux de la part du
chancelier de faire ça et je pense que
ça remis l'allemagne qui en 2003 était
quand même un peu moribond mais avec les
perspectives de l'allemagne époque ça
quand même tout changer de même
suède quand elle a fait ses réformes
avec 90 la pérenniser son modèle social
qui autrement aujourd'hui ont été coulés
n'existerait plus donc c'est ça qu'il
faut bien comme il faut bien comprendre
c'est notre enjeu actuellement enfin sur
l'épargné ce n'est pas un problème plus
général y un problème effectivement de
de déséquilibre actuellement entre
l'épargné et en pâtir
les pagnes sur l'offre et la demande
donc ce qui se passe actuellement c'est
que il ya une demande excédentaire pour
donner par une sur des produits sûrs et
ça pose des problèmes sur lesquels je
veux bien revenir par la suite ce qui
s'est passé c'est que ya problème
offre/demande je suis économiste donc je
commence par l'offre et la demande et
dans casse sur le marché d'offres la
quantité des pagnes sur a diminué au
cours du temps tout simplement parce
qu'on pensait que des produits étaient
sûrs jusqu'à récemment un bon du trésor
une obligation d'état d'apple ocde était
considéré comme 100% sûr d'un point de
vue prudentielles tient que vous ayez
pas besoin de mettre deux capitales en
face si vous étiez une banque on sait
maintenant que malheureusement les
obligations du trésor dans l' ocde ne
sont plus forcément sur donc il ya des
actifs sûrs qu'ils ont disparu en
quelque sorte de 1 pour l'immobilier
vous savez que aux états unis ont jugé
que l'immobilier était complètement sûr
alors pas dans une ville bien sûr parce
que c'est très risqué dans une ville
mais s'ils ont diversifié entre les
villes
on pensait que par la loi des grands
nombres on aura quelque chose d'assez
sur bon ça c'est vers et ne pas être
vrai puisqu'il ya eu les chocs agrégé et
donc il ya une offre d'actifs sûrs qui a
diminué en même temps il ya une
augmentation très fort d'actifs sûrs de
demande pour les actifs sûrs alors ça
d'abord été des fonds souverains la
chine et cetera qui ont investi beaucoup
dans les actifs sûrs en partie aux états
unis
vous avez entendu beaucoup parler de
titrisation des subprime qui a été
évidemment par manque de régulation a
été complètement dévoyé
mais au départ c'était une bonne chose
parce que ça permettait de dégager
le bilan des banques est de pouvoir
lever plus de fonds propres et en plus
sacré des actifs sur c'était un peu
d'humilité parce qu'il ya une demande
étrangère très forte pour créer des
actifs sûrs et comme les etats-unis ont
un système financier très développé ça
permet d'alimenter cette demande
enfin il ya la demande il ya d'autres
demandes et d'erreurs mende
réglementaires dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui évidemment les régulateurs
d'assurance de fonds de pension et de
banques dans le monde entier demande
beaucoup plus active sur et donc on est
dans un déséquilibre et par année entre
hearts d'épargné le monde d'epargne qui
conduit à des prix des actifs sur
extrêmement élevé ce qui veut dire des
taux d'intérêt extrêmement faible et
parfois qui pose des problèmes assez
considérable si vous voulez quand j'en
parle plus rudes en temps parler mais
c'est c'est vraiment un sujet après que
ça vienne au service de l'économie je
dirais oui mais il faut aussi qu'il ya
des perspectives dans l'économie ce que
les banques investiront dans les
entreprises si elle voit que ces
entreprises ont des perspectives
donc là on en revient sur toute la
confiance dans l'avenir on peut dire que
les banques on peut essayer de faire en
sorte que les banques investissent dans
les dents trouvées spéciales n'ont pas
envie et bat le ferons tout pour
dissimuler dans investissements parce
qu'elles veulent pas perdre de l'argent
dans les entreprises
donc il faut qu'elle voit une certaine
confiance dans l'entreprise si on veut
que les banques investissent de façon
effective dans l'ordre dans l'entreprise
pour ronger est très rapidement la
question qui était posée à propos de la
régulation à quelle échelle faut-il
envisager la réalisation de prendre un
secteur qui est celui de l'énergie
il ya des comparaisons à faire avec des
télécoms dans lesquels vous avez
travaillé par n'ai pas travaillé en
télécoms mais dans le système telecom
pour la question qui se pose est de
savoir est ce que c'est des régulateurs
qui se rend compte qu'il faut une
conférence entend ou est-ce que tu renom
un système à l'échelle
je dirais du continent du territoire où
l'économie se développe là en
l'occurrence
le marché d'énergie alors je vous
répondrais c'est clairement c'est le
second